fresh from San Antonio / Austin where I
went to look for some property very
happy with what I saw could have a ranch
now here's the thing daddy's not going I
don't think you're out of your [ __ ]
mind
well let me see he gets it take you
leaving and then you're in I gotta get
the kids and the ax to move to and
that's good no listen what happens in
California what happens in all these
progressive states Seattle Portland Los
Angeles and all these progressive things
is that I'm all about you know not and
I'm against police brutality but if you
want to [ __ ] start like look at New
York City de Blasio that [ __ ]
socialist is not behind a police Bartman
heart now yeah as Austin's - what
happened to us is shut down I know but
but but murderer mouth shootings are way
way up and [ __ ] New York and it's
going back to what it was in the [ __ ]
80s and 90s and I remember it very well
so it seems to me that all these super
progressive states can't control their
homeless situations their taxes go way
up
I get [ __ ] all for my taxes [ __ ] all but
I can save how much in taxes is how much
cheaper yeah and and and and I get
better schools yeah I'll go there I'll
go there and more land and and my dollar
goes twice as far
why the [ __ ] wouldn't I go to start up
the hall to him and play on the field
but but you know let but I'll let the
socialist states you know their thing
yep for sure super serious we could buy
bulls I would like to buy a bulls know
try to get milk cows first of all you
start on a baby ball now you get a baby
bro you learn you learn the baby you got
to have you got to have a groin pad
because your balls are gonna get crushed
so what I suggest lorries it what the
way I do it is I take a rope and I tell
my dick and balls
straight up cinch it onto my belly
button because you can't have them down
there cuz you're gonna fall and you're I
got low-hanging balls and you just gonna
make sure that the Bulldog hit daddy's
lids his new lids that's true too so
I'll wear a face mask now listen your
wear a helmet if my boat let's stick to
my balls for a second as if I come off
and one of my balls goes over here and
then I land back on it I got a bag I got
a kid I got a pancake now we grow with
the baby bull as he grows we grow as
right
Nixie no we're riding Ralphie there you
go he's a full-blown [ __ ] shiet hory now
my buddy Bob he decided he wanted to do
a TV show where he did all kinds of
danger and he learned very quickly the
problem with that is he could injure now
he got on he went to a bull riding thing
got on a pull and they said let's start
you on a horse on a bucking bronco let's
not to the horse was whatever well he
goes he's a very athletic strong guy and
he goes I got it written or he said I
can break a horse he says the guy goes
you can and he goes sure cuz he's a
macho guy gets on the horse and the
horse goes the horse goes oh you're on
me I don't like it
I'm gonna go this way and then I'm gonna
go that way my head and I'm gonna knock
out oh all of these tees so he came back
with a torn groin and no teeth no I'm
not about to bust a Bronco homeboy we
can buy a little baby bull all right
it's nice out with him that's right
we're gonna grow with him ride them we
ride them I want a bull that's a friend
probably bulls when they got balls you
never know they're rather unpredictable
that guy's cute as [ __ ] oh I like the
hair he thinks the baby goats are his aw
he's super and protects them dude how
much did you love Hotel Emma oh I loved
it we just lost lighting guys oh you
know what I look good yeah the way the
mold you think we had the neon that's me
I owed a pop it's not the light that
makes you look cool huh I'm in the same
light what do you know it's just life I
mean 53 years a son make you look old I
was in the Sun today what for a bike
ride this morning oh let the wind blow
back my hair yeah well put on a lock on
you liked Hotel Emma though huh Papa
didn't let you down so Hotel a mom is
one or more beautiful places I've been
ever and and I don't know if you know
this but they're gonna tear that that
brewery down and put a Walmart
distribution center in its place and
subdue that the guy who runs the whole
hotel and some guy said that a two
an architect and I mean the designer
came in and said uh uh uh we'll buy this
[ __ ] thing he had a lot of money from
his ham judge you scared me
I know oh no not now oh [ __ ] no that was
the idea oh no sure it's a gem yes it
[ __ ] Jana like they're gonna tear it
down turtle whoa no no no no that be a
crime it being a highway yeah I would
chain myself to the front door it would
be an architectural crime no hippies
chained themselves to like oak trees I
would chain myself to the floor vemma in
the row holding their sour cough in the
50s in the 60s in New York City they did
do that they tore down all kinds of
places like that in favor of blue eggs
Robert Moses wanted to create what's
called flow and he created all these big
impersonal buildings there was
architectural crime after architectural
how great was that place though it's
like an old tree in it cool it's like an
old tree it's one of a kind you know I
said it's like Shawshank Redemption if
it was in Pleasantville has that oldie
time vibe
everybody's like red everything is
everybody friend everything is
considered everything is consult
like every color the the bathroom and
there's the best best machine when I
build my house or if I get a house I'm
gonna ask them what exactly tiles
everything they used and do the exact
thing I'm hearing it's ridiculous yeah
it's incredible I love that stuff look
at that oh dude I might do my nuts we're
all up in that row you know what they
did for Papa they finally put a xxx one
in there hey I'm glad you the Campbells
- did you on my show like I'm glad I
included you on my show and you got a
suite and I got a regular room that's
cool we know why right
why is Hotel Hellmuth my hotel do they
book me my was tech me more fame the
headliner what the but it's oh no you're
it's Martin this el lol doesn't book
your hotel Bubba yeah but you gave me a
[ __ ] sweet - that's the second time
you've done that well no this on my show
they upgrade me huh they upgrade me no
you're friends with the owner and you
could have said hey get my boy in there
but you let me sit on that fourth floor
I can't I can't that's my room
I you don't get that room I get a room -
no papa yeah yeah so you and your
brother get the Suites Jay didn't get a
suite he's not a regular roaster just
you yeah there's only one suite my hotel
you didn't know about the hotel - I came
along you welcome
where else did we do that at uh Houston
uh he's dead um that was a bad hotel
anyway Houston place but hotel I'm
there's nothing worse than bad hotel I'm
not saying the hotel I'm doing the
Airbnb is unless it's like an idea much
better idea um doesn't nasty hit the
sour coffee sour I talked the owner this
morning he emailed me like how did you
stay everything up to par bla I said nah
you got the best hotel in the road I
love him back what you have sour coffee
yeah but he goes we do get complaints he
goes people either love it or they hate
it yeah I want just offer a dark roast
oh yeah exactly have have to have two
beers light and dark are everything
can't be sour as [ __ ] we can't find a
dark - bummer yeah cuz that one coffee
shop that's near is absolutely get their
beans from its come out local it's so
bad full I'm sorry I'll do spackle but
also do better
I mean why tried that coffee it was so
sour I had it twice I hope they're
listening cuz they should actually do
thing about it I tasted it it was so
citrusy so Center some people like that
but for the regular drinker like me who
looks like a little bit I want some
chocolate once it was iced tea like
lemonade sour misty I had to throw it
away I took two sips and I was like I
can't drink this I'd rather drink
[ __ ] whoo that's not how to drink
that's not I make coffee it's not - it's
just not that's why I gonna shoplift
those real light beans
ha ha I guess more caffeine though I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm here for flavor
Bubba yeah you you you can make money
sometimes with that because people well
they're doing caffeine rush yes the
hipster movement I guess I don't know
yeah he goes yeah we get a lot of people
either love it or hate it I'm like what
do you just offer both cover both bases
yeah
and also black rifles in San Antonio
have black rifle bullet or that the
other I thought they were in that's all
we know they're innovating well their
distributions out of Salt Lake City but
their main like my boy Matt all them
they all live in
we come to the show you know what they
probably text me but I forgot to text
back oh hey Matt best you can text me -
not your friend but you know he's as
much my friend as he's your friend
you think I don't know but he uh yeah
they're in San Antonio mmm the other
ones who introduced me to Hotel Emma
because I flew out there to shoot some
content for black rifle and they put me
up downs like black top [ __ ] Wow oh well
yeah but but you think Hotel image would
just connect with them and offer the
beans
I would imagine Oh drama black rifle
your next-door neighbor's ditch the
local spot and get with the beans baby
black rifle is a good name for it - I
like it black rifle it's intense but you
can just call whatever it's the only
thing I might be a little intense
you call whatever yeah yeah yep um I
went on a bike ride this morning I told
you right yep yeah Cruiser where'd you
buy credit Bettis down down on down the
beach and it was very empty how many
bumps did you hit all of them I hit all
the bumps
well I live in Venice now I know and by
a needle or well I've been in Venice for
25 years as you know off and on but
almost all on and it's the worst I've
seen it it's it's just well Skid Row and
ranan Skid Row and but thank you
politicians and it seems that they
really know what they're doing but I pay
crazy taxes and I live with homeless
people just across the street the [ __ ]
and my keys can hear them screaming and
say [ __ ] on your front door and you can
hear and you can smell it and end
because it's the trash is crazy so okay
that's that's it and you go to
Sacramento and you say stuff from there
like the ass are you looks frustrated
antsy Pelosi you know what's frustrating
is we're gonna leave right we're gonna
leave them like [ __ ] you Newsom he's
like see ya well it's almost like
they're airline you know like no it's
not that though because I'm gonna tell
you have you seen a lot of the companies
that are leaving though it's a big
problem for California because what
happens is well your tax base Falls and
the people get hurt are the people that
don't deserve to get hurt which are
middle-class class [ __ ] are working
hard working people because what happens
is as business exodus from California
see this it's more troubling than you
can see this doesn't it's more and more
businesses are leaving a home there you
go Brian eighteen hundred companies left
California in the year there you go
Texas no more destination for companies
thank you
now what does that tell you about on
stage on wit I'm moving to text they all
cheer then went don't tell anybody that
was true I don't want a lot of
Californians come out and voting for
liberal policies will also they [ __ ]
rule in that state too and I'm liberal
I'm a libertarian I just mean big
government taxation and [ __ ] [ __ ] you my
Jets are a little hot somebody cool my
Jets please what happened Bubba I don't
know boys I'm just I just I want to go
to Austin no I was just biking and I was
just around a bunch of hot like my city
lit above me my city of Los Angeles
I don't recognize and maybe I'm just
upset about this kovat thing oh you're
still upset about going I'm just upset
about gonna pass I know they got another
two weeks of crying wolf and
everything's up but the death rates all
the way down the invention like all
right we got apparently NPR for the
first time admitted that it's not as
deadly as babies right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]